وفي وقفه مع الحدث نتناول ابعاد قرار
مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي بوضع سقف
لسعر النفط الروسيه مواسم الاحمر وسيم
اهلا بك اولا ما تفاصيل هذا القرار وكيف
يطبق عمليا
القرار هو همم ليس يبحث منذ اشهر على
مستوى مجموعه الدول السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي الان اتخذ وبدا حيث تنفيذ يقوم
على وضع سقف 60 دولار لسعر البرميل برميل
النفط المصدر من روسيا ووضع عقوبات ومنع
استيراد همم نفط اذا كان يتجاوز هذا السعر
بحيث في منطق من فرض العقوبات يسم- عدم
الغاء او سحب النفط الروسي من السوق بما
يزعزع الاسواق في الوقت نفسه منع روسيا من
الاستفاده من ارتفاع اسعار النفط وعائدات
النفط تزامن هذا القرار الرجاء مع بدء حضر
تفرضه الاتحاد الاوروبي على استيراد النفط
الى الدول الاوروبيه النفط المنقول بحرا
الى دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وما يعني عمليا
تقريبا كل النفط الاوروبي او همم الاوروبي
المستورد من روسيا عمليا هذا القرار بيد
الدول التي فرضته لدول مجموعه السبع دول
اوروبيه واستراليا هي همم تسيطر مجموعه
السبع عمليا على معظم يقارب 90% من همم
شركات التامين على الشحن النفط بحر وخدمات
ان النقل البحري لان النفط وخاصه هذه
الشركات في اليونان بشكل اساسي بريطانيا
ايضا لا حصه كبرى في هذا الامر عمليا هو
انه عدم السماء التامين اينقلت نفط ان كان
تحمل نفطا روسيا مباع باكثر من 60 دولار
عمليا سيطبق بهذا الشكل
الضغط على روسيا سؤال كيف سيؤثر هذا
القرار على موسكو وما هي امكانيه الاخيره
للالتفاف على هذا القرار للتحدث عن قرارين
رجاء مساله بدا حظر النفط المصدر من روسيا
الى الاتحاد الاوروبي وتراجع من نحو 40%
في الاشهر الاخيره بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه
الان يوقف تقريبا بقى الحضر بشكل شبه كامل
حسب الخبراء هذا سيؤثر في المرحله الاولى
على همم الاقتصاد الروسي بمعنى انا عليها
ان تجد اسواق بديله هي موجوده في اسيا
بشكل خاص لكن مع فرض سقف على اثار النفط
سيكون بسعر اقاله وبالتالي قد يكون في
المرحله الاولى بشكل همم العائدات الماليه
اقل لكن تاثير فرض سقف على سعر النفط
الروسي محدود همم في المرحله الاولى على
على الاقل حتى عمليا الان سعر البرميل
المصدر من روسيا يقارب ال 65$ الفارق ليس
كبيرا وخساره روسيا ليست همم كبيره اضافه
الى ان امكانيه الالتفاف على هذه العقوبات
همم طبعا روسيا قالت نا لن تبيع للدول
التي تفرض سقفا لسار النفط لكن يمكن
التفاف كبيره منها انها ستبيع لدول اخرى
تشتري النفط وبحاجه وستكون مهتمه وهي اصلا
بدات منذ اشهر زياده كميات النفط المستورد
من روسيا كلهم كالصين او حتى التركي تركيا
المحروقات وغيره لا يعرف ان كان الروسيا
او سعوديه او غير ذلك وبالتالي امكانيه ان
يباع الى دول تركيا كان الهند ومن ثم يعود
الى الدول الاوروبيه باسعار اعلى وارده
وبارده جدا
ستتاثر بشكل اساسي عبر همم
يعني عاملين اساسيين اولا ان ترى همم اذا
قررت روسيا خفض الانتاج حتى الان اوبك لن
تخفيض الانتاج لكن درست قبل انتاج سيزعزع
الاصدقاء استقرار الاسواق سيرفع اسعار
النافطه بكل الاحوال مجرد الحد من تصدير
النفط عبر فرض هذه هذا الاجراء السقف
سيرفع اسعار المحروقات وخاصه هناك مواد
كالمازوت مثلا بحاجه للنفط الروسي على
المحطات التكرير في اوروبا لانها معتاده
على هذا الامر بحاجه لفتره للتاقلم مع
مصادر جديده سي يرفع اسعار المحروقات
واسعار النفط في الدول الاوروبيه والدول
الغربيه بشكل عام في وقت ان التضخم عال
وعال جدا كما تعرفينه في تداعيات حتى
اجتماعيه لهذا الامر النقطه الثانيه ان
همم شركات التامين
الغربيه على ناقلات النفط ستخسر عقودا لان
السن يعود هناك عدد ناقلات النفط وق يتم
تاسيس شركات اخرى في مواطن اخرى كالصين
كالهنتو الاخرى ستخسر على هذا الصعيد ايضا
لكن مر رجب ديدا هذا الاجراء غير مسبوق
رجاء هناك متضررين على الارجح الغايه منه
ضرب او الحد من عائدات روسيا لامن النفط
لكن هناك لا يقين ايضا لاننا نعرف كيف سته
رول روسيا هل ستتخذ قرارات راديكاليه في
مرحله ما بمعنى وقف الانتاج او او
كميات الانتاج او همم
تاخذ الدول الحنيفه لروسيا قسمهم قرارات
ايضا الاتجاه بمعنى ان تاثير وفاعليه هذا
القرار يعتمد على عوامل العداد تتعلق برده
تفعل روسيا لكن ايضا بالدول التي قد
تستفيد من هذا الاجراء ايضا لشراء النفط
بسعر ارخص الدول الاوروبيه لا شك ستتاثر
بتداعيات هذا الاجراء الذي اريد منه
الاضرار بروسيا بالدرجه الاولى
شكرا لك وسيم الاحمر اذا على وقفه مع
الحدث